in 21st century one of the best way to
manipulate and change DNA is CRISPR cast
9 and this is really revolutionized
molecular biology itself in this video
we'll look at a little bit about the use
of the CRISPR and how CRISPR can be
achieved in the laboratory so CRISPR
casts nine systems can be used to
generate knock in point mutations and
knock out lines so all sort of genetic
manipulation at DNA level is possible
using CRISPR not only DNA CRISPR has a
brilliant way of targeting a genomic
locus so a particular genomic loci can
be highlighted and can be imaged using
CRISPR mediated fish if you add a
fluorophore with the kazna enzyme and
allow the guide RNA to target a
particular genomic loci so the genomic
loci would be highlighted and that too
in a very specific manner then at the
RNA level or at RNA production level you
can also control you can perform
transcriptional activation and
transcriptional repression paradigm
using CRISPR so in this paradigm you use
the guide RNA to target this machinery
and this particular cache line instead
of cleaving just stay there near the
promoter now depending upon which
sequences they are binding them either
allow or facilitate the binding of the
RNA polymerase or they might hinder the
binding of RNA polymerase as a result
transcriptional activation or repression
could be achieved not only that the
futuristic gene therapy could be
designed or the custom build medicines
could be designed using this CRISPR
strategy yet we are far away from it but
it's not so far there are possibilities
now let's talk about that how CRISPR can
be achieved using cell culture method or
how it is performed in the laboratory
how the scientist can perform it in the
lab
so it is possible now to manipulate
human cells
human stem cells using CRISPR cast line
technology in this video we are going to
look at that so stay tuned till the end
of this video
exactly it would give you a flavor how
things are done in the lab so here are
some cells which are human embryonic
stem cell lines in a plate now what we
are going to perform is to perform
several Jimmy genetic manipulations in
these stem cells definitely the gene
that we want to manipulate we are going
to use a guide ER and against it and the
crystal machinery would cut it and
inside the cell there would be repair
machinery such as an h ej or homologous
directed repair mechanism mechanism and
when this repair mechanism would happen
we would incorporate our changes so you
are to perform that we have to add a
mixture of the cells several plasmids
about which I'm going to talk about and
a plasmid which would help you to scream
in this case it's a transient GFP
expression plasmid it would only tell
you that your transfection reaction has
worked properly the next step would be
electroporation so electroporation is
one of the efficient way of transferring
gene inside the cells using electric
current use from small pores on the cell
and the DNA that means in this case the
plasmids would get inside the cell after
that you take the transfected cells or
electroporated cells and you played them
on our fresh plate and allow them to
grow for a little while now since we
have a expression plasmid for GFP so the
transfected colonies would be
highlighted in green if you see under a
microscope now there is a chance that
the colonies which would be green or
which would be gfp positive they also
have other plasmids which is required
for the CRISPR so most probably some of
these colonies would be positive for
this genetic
so the next step would be sorting out
all the GFP positive cells from these
transfected cell pool after the fact
sorting when you really sort GFP
positive cells and collect them
separately
you put those gfp positive cells in a
new plate and allow the cells to grow
for a while after the cells grow you
would see in a plate there are colonies
and these colonies are achieved from one
single cell which was checked be
positive that means which was
transfected at least we know the
transfection has worked on those cells
but we yet don't know all the plasmids
are present in all of these colonies or
not in one colony it is possible that
all the three plasmids are present in
one colony it is also possible let's say
two plasmids are present the third one
is not there so what we really don't
know in which colonies all of the
plasmid are present and all the genetic
manipulation has taken place so what we
have to do under the microscope we have
to put collagenous and take out all of
these colonies and distribute these
single colonies into 96-well plates or a
24 well plate in each well you put one
colony and this one colony is derived
from one single clone from this you do
something which is very similar to
replica plating when the split is called
fluent you split them into two different
plates such that one plate is exact
replica of the other from the material
presenting one plate you extract the DNA
and used PCR based screening or
sequencing based screening and let's say
after screening you figure out that
these three wells are actually positive
for whatever you want whatever genetic
manipulation you wanted to do so you
track back to the root plate and take
out the cells from those plates and
expand them and keep them for future
uses and these this is your cell line
you revalidate with sequencing as well
so
let's look at what are the plasmids here
the plasmids are depending upon what
type of manipulation we are doing in the
first case that I'm going to share with
you we are going to do a knock in
experiment that means we are adding some
component inside the genomic DNA which
was not present many of the cases
scientists attach a GFP or a fluorophore
coding gene to mark many proteins
endogenously in this case the donor
plasmid has that sequence another
plasmid has the sequence forecast line
and also had the guide RNA which is
shown here in the plaque the third
plasmid is a transient GFP expressing
plasmid which would tell us the
transfection has worked or not so the
guide RNA would target the cache line
system to a particular genomic locus
which it should be targeted and then the
donor plasmid have sequence homology
with the strand which is targeted and
based on homology it would be actually
incorporated in the place of the double
strand break and a homology dependent
repair would take place using this
strand the the donor stand strand as a
template as a result the donor strand
should be incorporated into the genome
and using specific PCR primers you can
amplify the particular region because
you know this particular GFP containing
region is not present in this cell in
the cells normally right so the
wild-type would not show this band but
I'm at the but the mutant or the knockin
line would show a band which would
amplify a portion of the GFP and the
portion of the normal genomic DNA
so using that screening method you can
have an rough idea which cells cell
lines are positive then definitely you'd
send it for sequencing to understand the
incorporation of the sequence later on
you can also use the same principle to
target the guide RNA and instead of
having a donor plasmid you put a repair
all equal and this
repeal illegal is basically having a
point mutation inside of me now when
this repair oligo is replacing in the
double strand break it incorporates that
mutation inside the genome and you have
several ways to understand it many of
the cases a new restriction site would
appear there which was not previously
there so you can cut it with a different
restriction enzyme it would give you a
particular restriction balance but the
ultimate way to understand the point
mutation is to perform sequencing that
should tell you exactly the sequence
change has happened or not though CRISPR
looks highly precise high-throughput but
you need to screen as many as hundreds
of colonies to get specific mutants so
this is also a tedious process as well
in the laboratory but this process has a
lot of promise and it is really really
targeted so with that I would say
goodbye and if you liked this video give
it a thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you